[Musique]
alors le crypto challenge c'est un jeu
qui démarre à l'occasion de la fête des
mathématiques du 15 au 22 mars et qui va
durer deux mois l'idée c'est qu'il ya
des textes qui sont cryptés qui sont
codées et on se place dans la peau d'un
hacker un esprit monde ce qu'on veut et
on doit trouver ce qu'il ya derrière le
texte sans avoir de mots de passe
l'objectif c'est de jouer avec les
mathématiques de jouer avec les langues
vivantes de se casser un peu la tête et
voilà c'est de s'amuser
pour participer il suffit de créer un
compte sur le site
on va choisir un texte on va choisir la
langue et le niveau qu'on souhaite
et puis après si on a réussi à le
décrypter ben c'est comme si on avait
mis un bulletin pour faire un tirage au
sort et le
mi mai il y aura un tirage au sort dans
mon collège et les personnes qui ont
compté tirés au sort gagneront 1
un trophée qui sera fabriquée aux fab
lab de la verrière et à la six niveaux
différents c'est à dire que le niveau 1
c'est des niveaux très facile qui sont
accessibles dès l'école primaire
tous les textes commence par salut je
m'appelle et ça va jusqu'au niveau 6
houla faut vraiment être tenace bien
aimé les énigmes et les textes sont
quand même plus compliqué c'est vraiment
ouvert à tout public
c'est à dire que le principe du site
c'est que c'est les autant les enfants
que les adultes qui peuvent participer
il ya des dispositifs qui sont un peu
particulier sur le site s'il ya des
professeurs qui veulent faire l'activité
en classe entière mais c'est vraiment
ouvert à tout le monde
et sachant que les textes sont
évidemment français mais aussi dans des
langues étrangères par exemple si on est
en train d'apprendre l'anglais et qu'on
veut se tester ben on peut le faire